hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video watch und ich stehe in meinem
kleiderschrank bin umgezogen ist das
ganze ja nie so öffentlich gemacht aber
ich befinde mich gerade meiner neuen
busse das hat hier ich stehe in meiner
neuen wohnung gudiberg schon
es hat ja okay wir gerade als jetzt
nicht so krass aber wir sind überall
noch keine klamotten drehen und in
meinem eigentlichen arbeitszimmer ist
auch kein teppich der da irgendwie den
schall aus nimmt deswegen stehe ich
gerade in meinem kleiderschrank kopf des
ok für euch aber nicht geht
ihr solltet ihr bei twitter fragen zu
senden und die werde ich im heutigen
video beantworten wenn rot komplementär
zu grün ist und mit dem titelverteidiger
2 zu 1 unterlegen war
du wachst du berlin nicht dass wenn ich
ins video kommen fresse ich meinen
laptop auf ok user mit dem namen pixel
crafter hd du hast es gibt bietet und
wir haben doch alle gehört und jetzt
haben sie auch alle gelesen und alles
mitbekommen dass geschrieben wenn du in
video commons fristet ein laptop live
vor kamera auf du machst die tage in
video bietet dass er mich und eure
aufgabe als community ist es dann mir
das irgendwie zu zeigen weil ich es
natürlich nicht mit wenn da irgendwas an
mich tötet weil die ganze rede schon
fast voll sind ich will sehen dass du
den laptop frist wann stellst du die
neuen klamotten aus dem lokal shop vor
denn mittlerweile sollten sie meisten
mitbekommen haben ab dem 1 12
an diesem ersten tag des dezembers
passiert dort ein shop relaunch das
heißt es werden einige produkte
rausgenommen und es werden auf 5 678
neue produkte in den shop neu
reingepackt ich werde am 29 november ein
video hochladen wo ich euch alle
produkte vorstellen die zwei tage später
am ersten zwölfter quasi live gehen
werden in den lukas schott mainz
netteren instagram folgen würde ich
hättet ihr auch schon ein paar produkte
gesehen hatte habe ich beispielsweise
schon den neuen turnbeutel gezeigt der
im dunkeln leuchtet den neuen zweiter
hat sich als selber die tage schon mal
anlass ist nämlich dieser hier ist der
vorteil wenn man in seinem
kleiderschrank ein video aufnehmen aber
jetzt hier live für euch im video wenn
ihr jetzt gerade dran seite es wird auch
ein top socket geben also dieses teil
hier wirklich das quasi auf euer handy
oder auf eure handy höhe und das ist
übelst resistent also dass klebte recht
fest drauf und das könnt ihr einerseits
ein klappen dann ist es total dünnen
oder ihr klappt es wirklich raus dann
könnt ihr euer handy irgendwie so
hinstellen auf dem tisch oder ihr haltet
einfach so fest können besser im safety
machen oder besser einfach festhalten
also ich kann mittlerweile nicht mehr
ohne die spots doppelt und dann habe ich
mir gedacht ja das ist wohl einfach ein
smiley drauf zu machen so ist ultra cool
also den pop shop wird auch am ersten
zwölf neu gema man machen weiter mit den
nächsten fragen wie viel uhr ist es bei
mir ist es gerade 19 uhr zwei kannst du
dein ellbogen mit einer zunge berühren
[Musik]
wachstum anders als meine lieblingstiere
sind natürlich auf der eins alpakas weil
es einfach die süßesten und fleißigsten
und nettesten und lieben tiere der welt
sind auf platz zwei sind dann
erdmännchen weil die einfach ultra
verteilt sind und auch der dreikampf
anders und ich habe letztens ein video
bei facebook gesehen muss eine ultra
tollpatschiger panda irgendwie frau song
werther irgendwie weg gelaufen ist
irgendwo runtergefallen
ich mag kann das ja wie sieht deine neue
wohnung aus also ihr seht ja gerade
schon meinen kleiderschrank weil das
einfach gerade der ort ist wo es noch am
wenigsten halt weil dem rätseln derzeit
noch keine möbel drin und es steht noch
relativ leer
das hier wird auch noch alles verloren
doch mit mehr klamotten an sich hat
bisher nur die wichtigsten sachen mit
rübergenommen aber ihr solltet mich an
mittlerweile alle kennen und wissen dass
ich jemand bin der sein privatleben
gerne privat hält und solche sachen wie
beispielsweise in einen wohnraum eine
wohnung jetzt umgehen auf der plattform
youtube publizieren möchte das heißt ich
kann mich wirklich nicht versprechen
dass ich eines tages eine rundum machen
werde aber ich werde vielleicht mein
arbeitszimmer mal zeigen oder so wenn
ihr das überhaupt wollt also wenn ihr
das wollt dann schreibt man die
kommentare und dann sehe ich darin dass
enorm viele kommentare sind das dass ihr
daran nicht interessiert sein würdest du
lieber eine aufs maul bekommen wenn du
rasierklinge gewohnt hast oder lieber
nadeln warum sollte mir jemand aufs maul
hauen wenn ich rasierklingen oder ein
warum sollte ich überhaupt rasierklingen
oder nadeln im mund haben welche farbe
in zahlen alphabet ist dein
lieblingstier ticker wer von euch hat
die fragen rausgesucht wenn pizzaessen
sprache hat wer willst du sie trotzdem
essen ja
hey ich glaub ich werde nur noch im
knast wie wäre es mit einem schlafanzug
in lucka schock ich selber halte nichts
von schlafanzügen also dass wie ich
schlafe ist einfach eine boxershort und
ein t shirt an alle den schlafanzug
wollen
ich kann mich auf jeden fall schon mal
sagen dass jetzt zum ersten zwölf leider
kein schlafanzug in den luca shop kommen
vielleicht kommt etwas anderes was mit
dem bett zu tun hat aber wartet mal ab
wer hat den keks aus der dose geklaut
wenn ich jetzt was komisches frage ist
die frage dann komisch da hast du ne
komische frage das war definitiv komisch
was hast du dir gedacht als du uns in
einem video erzählt hast dass du viel
liter durchfall geschissen hat so ein
paar freunde von mir gucken wir auch mal
meine videos und als dieses video
gesehen habe habe ich so circa von jedem
bei whatsapp seminar tisch bekommen von
wegen hacker das wollten wir gar nicht
wissen
du sparst ich esse gerade du hast alles
kaputtgemacht sari ja gefragt was los
wenn ich gefragt hast du schon mal
gepackt
[Musik]
ja ich habe schon mal gepackt warum ist
es nachts kälter als draußen also ich
meine wenn man nachts draußen ist dann
wenn man nachts kette als nachts kette
als das was ihr vom video meine damen
und herren wie vorhin schon gesagt wenn
ihr der ruhm zu wollen schreibt x room
to indy kommentare ich dachte halt
einfach so ich wollte mir den ganzen tag
unterwegs und immer noch ein bisschen
angeschlagen und krankt deswegen läuft
es einfach so raus wie es ein paar
fragen beantworte ich hoffe das war in
ordnung für euch ihr findet hier oben
ins mal angewendet wenn ihr darauf wie
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren dann seid
ihr neuer abonnent beim einem kanal ist
irgendwie logisch wenn ihm ein kanal
abonniert und hier unten findet ihr
irgendein anderes video eingeblendet ich
würde mal sagen dass von vor ein paar
tagen wo ich euch die besten männer
quintett das vorgestellt habe ist auch
sehr unterhaltsam